let's just bring you some breaking news  regarding the rmt union which is saying  thousands of rail workers will stage  three days of strike action later this  month this is in dispute over pay and  jobs the rmt union saying its members at  network rail and 13 train operators are  going to walk out across the uk  on tuesday the 21st thursday the 23rd  and saturday the 25th of  june the t has also announced another  24-hour strike on the london underground  that's going to take place on the 21st  of june uh this is in a separate row we  understand over jobs and pensions the  union says it is the biggest strike on  the railways since  1989 that's information we have here at  sky news and more on that  as we get it